[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 me acompañe en el estudio rosa
pérez mateo rosa bienvenida feliz mañana
del lunes comenzamos una nueva semana de
nuestro programa y vamos a ir con las
elecciones en colombia pero con los
medios internacionales comenzamos en la
región por la tercera de chile y la
nación y una argentina buenos días raúl
exactamente como siempre hemos hecho una
pequeña selección de medios de
comunicación que destacan en este caso
en su portada en papel los resultados de
esta primera vuelta presidencial aquí en
colombia y sin embargo hay que destacar
raúl que ayer en la sede de petro la
sede principal de aquí de bogotá había
cientos de medios de comunicación
internacionales y nacionales acreditados
sin embargo cuando hablamos ya de las
portadas en papel no son tantos los
medios de comunicación alrededor del
mundo que llevan los resultados de estos
comicios en portada pero si es el caso
de la tercera de chile que le da mucha
importancia pues a estos resultados no
dice pues un poco petro y hernández al
balotaje no a los dos candidatos que se
enfrentarán para la presidencia de
colombia
a los porcentajes obtenidos por un lado
por gustavo petro con un 40% y por otro
lado por rodolfo hernández al que muchos
medios de comunicación como la sien en
la cnn se refieren como el trump
colombiano no con este 28 por ciento de
los sufragios a su favor y precisamente
en relación a los resultados no de
rodolfo hernández titula el medio
argentino la nación que dice sorpresa en
colombia ganó petro pero habrá ballotage
con el populista hernández y dice lo
siguiente el candidato de la izquierda y
ex guerrillero obtuvo el 43 por ciento
en la primera vuelta el outsider y ex
alcalde protagonizó un verdadero hito al
desplazar a gutiérrez su rival de
derecha y porque sorpresa no porque
titula así porque hace unas semanas a
raúl se daba prácticamente por hecho que
de en el caso de haber segunda vuelta
sería federico gutiérrez digamos el
representante de la derecha más
establishment más tradicional el rival
de gustavo petro y finalmente pues como
decíamos no ha sido así y bueno aquí ya
vemos un poco la importancia de los
adjetivos porque este medio de la nación
describa petro como exguerrillero y sin
embargo a rodolfo como exalcalde
mientras que les haya gustado petro
también fue alcalde de aquí de la
capital de bogotá y precisamente pues a
rodolfo lo cita como outsider aunque
pues bien es empresario y tal y como se
ha filtrado pues en muchos audios donde
habla él mismo se ha aprovechado digamos
de forma voluntaria no de las
desigualdades perpetradas por este
sistema económico pero bueno pasamos a
otros medios internacionales y además
unos o comentarios personales bastante
preocupantes rosa vamos a ir ahora con
el país españa y el 'new york times' en
estados unidas pues sí y un poco el
enfoque como decíamos es el mismo petro
gana las elecciones en colombia con unos
resultados históricos para la izquierda
y se medirá con hernández y en este caso
el país a de españa dice que bueno
califica digamos a hernández como
populista y a petro como izquierdista
mientras que el nivel james dice lo
siguiente dos candidatos presidenciales
populistas se dirigen al balotaje
mientras el fervor contra el actual
gobierno arrasa en el país y si bien
raúl hay muchas definiciones de
populismo lo que es poco honesto digamos
intelectualmente sin duda poner a petro
ya hernández en el mismo saco no y
además también rosa que el populismo
tampoco es bueno no a ninguno de los
sentidos pero bueno vamos ahora con los
medios colombianos empezamos por el
tiempo uno de los más importantes del
país exacto que dice petro y rodolfo
arrancan de cero en la batalla por el
cambio y es que esto es una de las
conclusiones no de los análisis más
destacados y es que el hecho de que
rodolfo hernández que se presente como
anti establishment puedo poner ciertos
palos a las ruedas al discurso de
gustavo petro lo que se presenta como el
cambio frente al continuismo no y al no
pues finalmente rivalizar con un
candidato pues de la derecha tradicional
pues se le complica un poco la retórica
tan clara que tenía hasta ahora y el
tiempo dice que pues rodolfo hernández
tiene un discurso muy fuerte uno de sus
puntos de esta campaña contra la
corrupción aunque poco argumentado y de
hecho el mismo está imputado en un caso
de corrupción recordemos también destaca
que es rodolf hernández ha tenido un
manejo muy hábil de las redes sociales
lo que le ha dado a conocer a nivel
nacional y algo que gustavo petro de
hecho le reprochó o no que la corrupción
no se combate vía tick tock también le
reprochó recordemos ayer tras conocerse
los resultados que hubiera seguido
porque se declarara fna de adolf hitler
entre otros comentarios que han sido
rescatados de la hemeroteca del llamado
ingeniero pues a lo largo de esta
campaña y también el tiempo señala que
pues se rodó al fernández optó por no
presentarse a los debates presidenciales
a los últimos recordemos porque
consideraba que no le favorecía y que
pues a sus potenciales votantes tampoco
pues se les iba a importar el respecto
rosa el espectador de petró hernández un
mensaje de rechazo a la vieja clase
política y el espectador se pregunta qué
va a pasar finalmente con él con el
apoyo de federico gutiérrez no porque
como siempre pasa en los procesos
electorales donde hay primera y segunda
vuelta pues la fuerza que se queda a las
puertas del balotaje suele ser clave en
función de a quién de sus apoyos de cara
a esta segunda vuelta y si se pregunta
el espectador si rodolfo hernández va a
aceptar los apoyos de esta clase
política no del establishment a la que
tanto ha denigrado igual lo tiene que
hacer rosa para poder realmente tener un
triunfo en la segunda vuelta es igual lo
vamos a realizar con nuestro primer
invitado el día rosa muchísimas gracias
nos vemos mañana con más